consistency i have so many friends who
are like i'm working on something big
like it's big bro i'm sure you all have
this friend who's like oh i've got [ __ ]
in the works
yeah and then it's like two years later
oh it's it's coming yeah it's coming
it's coming it's coming and then they
upload it and then they're like
that's it i'm i'm famous i'm done and
they like
realize they have to do it yeah yeah the
amount of channels i've seen that have
more update videos than actual content
on their channel they are staggering
this is the and it's that it's that
thing right where i think
everyone who watches youtube idolizes
that youtuber who uploads once every
three months
and it's a legendary yeah yeah yeah
right but in reality right
there's only a very small room for
channels like that yeah only a select
few who can do that
yeah and in reality most of us have to
just keep [ __ ] uploading
that's just how it is because a lot of
us just aren't aren't capable of putting
in that amount of work into your video
like uh yeah
i love uh what's his name uh frederick
knudsen what's his name oh down the
rabbit hole down the rabbit hole
his videos i don't mind how long it
takes him because that yeah that [ __ ]
that man must put in
i don't even want to know how much work
he puts in i love that wings of
redemption oh it's like the two and a
half hours
i've watched like four times
in the same sense you know like the
right opinion for example right exactly
yeah
i watched his [ __ ] or four hours like
when i was sick i watched this four hour
video in one sitting of his nicado
avocado video
and i thought i was losing my damn mind
watching this but but you know
again it's it's a very everyone wants to
be that channel right the really well
respected channel that does that yeah
but unfortunately
i think as a youtuber you'll know very
quickly on if you can if you can do that
or not if that's your kind of thing some
people can
can do that a lot of people just just
gotta accept that you're gonna be that
dude
who makes one one video every two days
yeah like there's nothing wrong with
that like just embrace it
there's a space for that on youtube yeah
there's a space for everything if you've
got to make slime videos
don't i'm kidding i for one love the
slime videos
to be honest with you when i discovered
that like a week ago i was like
okay you know i kind of like it not
gonna lie you know what the biggest
pitfall i think a lot of youtubers fall
down is that when they get one
successful video series they're like
make ten of them do it again ten of that
do it again and i think you mean every
top ten
oh my god like you meet people and they
make they just make repeats and repeats
of the same video
yeah and you've got to realize like if
that's the only thing that's pulling
people in
you haven't made any any other
foundation to keep people engaged
yeah you're gonna be pissed yeah when
that stops eventually you're gonna get
[ __ ] bored of doing it
yeah you kind of got not really anything
else that's why i like you
you're gonna burn out eventually like we
talked about putting a foundation is
actually
really really important something that
most people don't think about because
most people would just want to get
as successful as they can as quickly as
they can use more views
like i've been doing the cosplay series
and yeah i've done a [ __ ] ton of those
yeah but i do one of them about every
two three months yeah so they're really
well spaced out and it's really
important to just
make sure you're diversifying it so that
yeah i sound like a [ __ ] business
meeting
make sure the synergy of your uploads
are diverse enough
to get the cooperation i mean that's the
exact problem i had with uh anthony
senpai right
like i haven't done one in [ __ ] like
seven months eight months or something
and people
to this day ask me when's the next day
when you bring it out people are gonna
be like yeah
when i do when i do it eventually maybe
uh
it's gonna be great right yeah but the
reason why i stopped making those for
the longest time is because that's
exactly what happened
i went it was really successful the
first time and i was like yeah i'll do
it
every week let's do it over and over and
over again i've made like 60 answering
samples right yeah and now at this point
i'm like
i want to do something else with it i
just don't want to like upload another
[ __ ] q a again because that's
essentially what it is it's just a
[ __ ] cue
i also just want to just make sure
people know that at the end of the day
which is [ __ ] dudes who just
talk [ __ ] in front of a camera it's like
not a big deal like why do people get
like
people with 10 000 subs stuck in egos
and i'm like bro my job is literally
me being a clown i like do not like do
not think you're hot [ __ ] ever
i don't i don't know why people do that
either talk about japanese cartoons dude
that's sad
yeah dude
come on [ __ ] not your place jesus
christ